a month ago you were in med school being
taught by doctors today you are the
doctors there were five of us and now
it's just you and I and it can't be just
me Grey's Anatomy is saying goodbye to
Alex Karev
and honestly I'm emotional AF about it
following Thursday night's episode of
Grey's fans were given this nostalgic
trailer which took us back to the great
pilot in 2005 you need somebody my purse
a good
[Music]
ABC announced Justin chambers exit from
the show last month but it's been
unclear how he'd be written out until
now on Thursdays episode though we did
get some insights schools would close
people would hunker down buy candles and
eat everything in the refrigerator and
Camilla Luddington aka Joe aka Koretz
wife had he left me he didn't I think he
did I think he woke up one day and felt
the need to escape his life and me
I called his mom he wasn't there earlier
this month Christopher Knopf the show's
executive producer promised there would
be a clarity for fans about Koretz
departure a reminder though when we last
saw him
he'd been serving as the Chief of
Surgery at Pacific Northwest hospital
grace loans rival hospital and left to
go be with his mom Alex is going through
something with his family that he will
tell you about and he's ready because
he's a good guy and he loves you the
March 5th episode likely won't feature
any new Karev scenes though the show's
three hundred and fiftieth episode which
aired on November 14th was Justin's last
appearance in January Justin told ET
quote there's no good time to say
goodbye to a show and character that's
defined so much of my life for the past
15 years for some time however I've
hoped to diversify my acting roles and
career choices and as I turn 50 and
invest with my remarkable supportive
wife and five wonderful children now is
that time Justin is hardly the first og
Grey's character to exit in fact Ellen
Pompeo Chandra Wilson and James Pickens
are the only three who are still on the
series when we spoke with Patrick
Dempsey in 2018 he wished the cast and
crew success and even had some kind
words for Ellen Pompeo after a rumored
feud I wish them a lot of walking
continued success in I see people from
around the world that have now were
inspired to become doctors I think
that's pretty remarkable I think the
greatest legacy with everybody raised
Ellen Pompeo paid you the biggest
compliment saying that you are a tough
act to follow and that's why her
character has had a hard time finding
love how do you respond to that well
that yeah I mean it's um I think the
success of this ship that's a wonderful
compliment and thank you and I that was
a very special bond it was just there
was a magic to our connection
katherine heigl up the show in 2010 she
said this one asked about a possible
return I don't know I don't know if I
would or if I wouldn't and though Sarah
drew wasn't an original cast member she
was a fan favorite who was ousted from
the series in 2018 she said this about
the chances of coming back I will say
okay
Christopher Knopf did recently say she's
trying to get somebody back oh yeah yeah
would it ever maybe be you I I mean
that's not up to me so if they ask look
I know I will never close the door on my
family at graze so it just it just it
just depends
so all hope is not lost there is a
chance Justin chambers could return
especially as speculation builds that
the show will soon end
yes we're starting to think about how
you would end to show this iconic Lee
this iconic how do you end it all right
guys that's it for today for all the
latest on Grey's Anatomy and your other
favorite shows stick with all things ET
until next time I'm Katie crafts and bye
for now